at the southern border because new video
shows a big group of migrants slipping
through a gap in the Border fence into
Arizona apparently not finished there
yeah they cut it uh our border seems to
be breaking records every day with a
number of criminals being apprehended
over the past weekend but then let go
crazy Griff Jenkins live at the
epicenter of it all Eagle Pass Texas hey
Griff hey good morning guys and let me
show you we have yet another large large
group arriving here right now behind me
now it is
38° you can see my breath it is wind is
blowing it's frigid but yet as the
light's coming up and I'm going to have
my cameraman dalon just push in there
bear with me with the lighting
conditions but this is what we've been
seeing every single day not sure how big
this group is but you can see just
beyond the the bodies here lining up on
that razor wire is the river yesterday
there were more than 22 200 migrant
Crossings here just in the Del Rio
sector I encountered one man from Angola
they had uh some 20 plus Haitians seeing
Haitians again is really alarming the
officials because I haven't seen him for
a while since going back two years when
of course you saw the tens of thousands
under the bridge in Del Rio this is the
second day in a row we've had Haitians
of concern here and that is all part of
the problem now if we want to split the
screen possibly or take you out to
lukeville you can see the lukeville uh
numbers also surging and that is what
the officials are sounding the alarm on
because we haven't seen those now among
the migrants coming across and in
lukeville you've got people from
Bangladesh Egypt China Sagal all over
the world in addition to in this area I
should point out it is still largely
Venezuelans but also people from
Honduras Guatemala Nicaragua and we've
been harping on that stat that 5,000
migrants a day are being released in the
country that's pulling these people it
is a magnet unlike We've Ever Seen On
the Border officials know it now
lawmakers like Tony Gonzalez knows it
but yet the administration doesn't seem
to be doing anything and not realizing
what they are doing to pull them the
border patrol Chief by the way tweeted
out yesterday a figure I gave you which
was the 20,000 migrants over the weekend
but in addition let me show you this
tweet he put a few more details you see
here they also had three sex offenders
three gang members a few of their
convictions luden lascivious acts with a
child under 14 unbelievable I got a
chance yesterday to sit down with the
independent mayor Rolando Selenas here
in Eagle Pass I asked him about all this
and about the administration have they
come down here and visit he says no I
said do you feel like they're going to
do anything for you here's what he had
to
say we just kind of have to fend for
ourselves here in Eagle Pass we we do
our best with what we have it's
unacceptable we feel 100% ignored by the
federal government by the administration
they don't bother to give us a call they
don't nobody bothers to tell us what the
plan of action
is and just lastly before I let you go
I'm just going to push one more time
because we're just getting some light on
these migrants and make the point which
is why these agents are so overwhelmed
here in the Eagle Pass area you've got
no more than about 40 agents On Any
Given shift they've been working around
the clock being overwhelmed 50 to1 60
to1 out in lukeville we learned the
ratio of illegal immigrants Crossing to
border patrol agents on the line it's
200 to1 that is creating the challenge
that they have here and it is one that
just simply isn't giving them a break
that's why they're reaching a Breaking
Point that's why morale is suffering and
as the sun comes up and I wish I had a
little more light I'd give it to you
you're going to see this all day long
yesterday we had at least four large
groups of well over a hundred we'll see
what we're in for today guys I'll send
it back to youy hey Griff what was this
did you know Congress is talking about
going home without a deal without any
type of Asylum changes without any type
of money for more border patrol what's
this going to look like in over the next
3 four weeks as Congress enjoys their
holiday well you can see Brian these
live pictures again just to point out
it's 38° here this is typically the time
of the year when you have very few
migrants covering simply because it's
very uncomfortable and very difficult we
had just the other day a one-month-old
infant that was born on the journey in
the Darian Gap just the harshest of
conditions and yet Congress it sounds
like according to Republican senator
James langford's going to go home
without a deal because the White House
is only talking to Democrat Senators not
Republicans and if you talk to any
official out here I'll leave you with
this thought they say listen funding is
great but we need a lot more than
funding we need policy changes we need
to raise the fear threshold of meeting
the credible fear we need a rocket
docket of judges to quickly deny asylums
and we need to increase massively the
deportations to send the message that
migrants shouldn't come yet all you can
see in the way of deterrence is CBP puts
out a tweet every 6 hours or so saying
don't come you won't be let in but
that's not the message they're people
behind you who who are those people
walking behind you are those migrants
trying to get over on the other side of
the chain
people the these These are migrants that
are crossing at two different locations
to my East and my West and coming across
the river and they'll put them anley
Just in one single file line and at this
point they'll be marched there's a lot
of them that's why I'm waiting for just
a little more light to come up they're
going March them right up behind me and
take them to the top of the hill Beyond
me and that's where they'll do what they
call mobile processing they'll check to
see if their ID find out who they are we
had just the other day on Saturday we
had one individual in just the one quick
mobile processing hit for sex offender
they handcuffed him and separated him
but this is where we also will find out
where they're from yesterday one guy
from Angola hey Griff uh as you pushed
in and it's dark enough to to see that a
number of the migrants are looking at
their cell phones and I just out of
curiosity you know a lot of these people
have have come to that location just
across from Eagle Pass on the trains and
they've been walking for days or weeks
or months where do they plug in their
cell phones how do they get the
electricity to charge those things
up that's a great question we don't
fully know the answer to that although I
will say this and I interviewed uh a
migrant that was telling us that
immigration officials along the way this
was last week told me that that the
immigration officials had given migrants
GPS coordinates of where to go in ped
negras that's the Mexican town across
the river from us to get to this
specific point directing migrants right
here so I'm I'm willing to to surmise
that many of them are using their phones
to make sure they're going to the right
spot why because they know that they
will be Tak into custody they're going
to get warm this morning that's for sure
they're going to get those shiny myar
blankets they'll get probably water and
they'll be taken to a processing center
not far from here where they will warm
up and then ultimately they will be
released and we have found on multiple
occasions uh the migrants that have
filled out the cbp1 app on their phones
but yet still crossed illegally because
they got tired of waiting but they were
holding on to that cbp1 application to I
guess give them some Assurance just in
case they had a problem being released
they'd have that proof uh as as another
thing and you're looking now by the way
just at more of them coming along that
line as you're pointing out Angley
that's CU they've just crossed and being
directed here it's it's happening here
with the efficiency of of an Amazon
operation of like your Christmas
shopping happening here just orderly and
I got to give my hats off to these
border patrol and National Guardsmen
down here because this is what they've
been handed they don't make the decision
they don't set the policy and they're
doing the best job they can in difficult
conditions if you can explain to our
audience cuz I see this barrier right
here I think Texas DPS and National
Guard put this razor out here uh Who's
down there doing the processing has
border patrol already made it down there
because normally Texas DPS will take
them in and wait detain them uh until
the border patrol gets there has border
patrol already arrived there on the
scene
that that's that's right they have
Lawrence and um I I I really I'm not
sure it would quite work if I tried to
spin the camera because I just want to
stay on this shot because we're getting
a little more light so we can really
start to begin to see the size of the
group uh yesterday's morning group
turned into uh in excess of 400 but but
where the river is we've got the
National Guard just to receive them but
then about a th000 yards 500,000 yards
Beyond where I'm standing up a winding
road at the top of the hill you can see
border patrol and and and a bus already
waiting in fact dton my cameraman's
going to absolutely yell at me but D is
it possible to spin around and just show
this is a little bit rough yeah and and
you can just see beyond us we we'll try
and show this to you you can see a
border patrol truck and you can see a
bus that's already waiting and I
apologize for the for the rough TV uh
turn here we're making but just since
you asked lawren you can see at the top
of the hill you've got up here a border
patrol truck at the top that's a green
stripe and then a bus that bus just out
of view is waiting so they're going to
try and process them as fast as possible
but right now we've got more and more
coming across that River all right and
gri because uh you mentioned the sun
coming up we're going to check back in
with you in about a half an hour as the
sun comes up and we can see more of
what's going on right there and Eagle
Pass what a mess Griff is the most
experienced border patrol reporter in
the country and he's never anything like
it yeah been there a lot I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian killme and I'm anglehart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis